hi welcome back uh sorry for the delay
in uploading uh instead of our regularly
scheduled video today we're going to
have a quick comparison between this uh
my laptop and uh this uh a paper A4
notebook which one's lighter uh they
feel about the same call that a drawer
which one's
thinner about the
same which one's better at editing
videos that are more than few minutes
long uh hang on let me
check yeah neither of them can do that
at all I have the first video all shot
and worked out uh and I've been trying
to edit it for a long time now but it's
just not going to work the laptop is not
powerful enough so long story short I'm
building a PC parts are on the way um
I'm going to delete this video obviously
when I get the actual one up but just uh
have patience and I'll see you again
[Music]
soon quiet onet